[Music]
i'm john scott and i was there the day
fox launched 25 years ago
i'd worked at other networks and i knew
the reputation of the people who were
starting this thing and
i thought it was worth a chance i'm john
scott television news kind of a
single person's game hours are horrible
there's a lot of travel it's tough to
have a family and work in tv news but i
already had a family 11 months after we
launched our fourth child was born i
like to think that she was the first
official fox news baby i used to bring
my kids into the newsroom and into the
studios and
my youngest was this chubby little baby
and now that little kid is
all grown up you know 25 years we were
the little engine that could
we felt like we had a mission and we
wanted to make it work